(rock music)
(laughter)
- Am I right, knights?
Maids are always like
my hand hurts from this spindle.
(laughter)
OK that's my time, you guys.
OK you guys have been great.
- Yeah yeah, man.
Hey yo give it up for Dustin, y'all.
Give it up for Dustin.
Yeah that guy is dope.
Alright well this next pantaloon
has been seen fooling around castles
all around kingdom
which comes to no surprise
cause she's woman!
She's gonna try and tell jokes.
Isn't that absurd?
(laughter)
Give it up for Jesterca.
Jesterca.
(clapping)
- Alright make some noise
if your only function in society
is financial benefit to a lord. (chuckles)
But what do I know?
I'm just a maiden wearing pants?
(laughter)
(whistling)
- You weren't that bad
for a female jester.
- You realize how
insulting that is, right?
Even though you're
trying to compliment me.
- Do you want another drink or not?
- Yes.
All the brandy.
(indistinct talking)
- Hey.
Not so bad for.
- A female jester.
Yeah.
Heard it.
- Ah c'mon.
Perhaps if you made your jokes
a little more relatable like Todd.
- I mean they're not called
hand maidens for nothing.
Am I right?
Yeah? (laughter)
Yeah, yeah.
You know what I'm talking about.
- I told him that.
You did it.
You did it!
- Yeah! (laughter)
Whoo! (audience cheering)
- My jokes are super relatable.
So the other fortnight
I wasn't feeling well
and I called in plague.
A king walks into a tavern.
- [Voiceover] Get off the stage!
- Shut up, Todd!
- Like called in sick.
- I get it.
- This is bullshit.
The male jesters go up there
and just make jokes about their swords
the entire set but if
I talk about anything
that's interesting to me
I get my head cut off.
Literally the booker threatened
me with the guillotine.
- Right.
If you just made your jokes
a little more relatable
to the audience I think
they would start laughing.
- Like brutally fighting on my horse
while oppressing women
and receiving all the benefits
of male privilege?
- (laughs) Yes!
Those are real humdingers.
Hey.
Oh hey c'mon.
Don't cry now.
Hey.
Warm up to Chad, OK?
Let's just go back to my room,
start writing jokes, make things funny.
(saxophone music)
- I guess I can't hate myself anymore.
- (laughs) Oh my god.
You're hilarious.
That was a yes.
- No.
No.
Hard no.
- Like a maybe?
- No maybe.
All no.
100 no.
- I just bought a horse.
(saxophone music)
(rock music)